in the last video i told you that if i
had a hyperbola with the equation x
squared
over a squared
minus
y squared over b squared is equal to one
that the focal distance
for this hyperbola is just equal to the
square root of the sum of these two
numbers
the square root of a squared plus b
squared in this video i really just want
to show you that and actually just so
you know you know this this situation
this equation right here this is a
particular hyperbola that opens to the
left and the right and that's because
that's those are the asymptote points
those would be the axes and that's
because the x term is positive if the y
term was positive and the x term had a
negative sign then the hyperbola would
open upwards and downwards like that
and the proof that i'm showing you in
this video it's just a bunch of algebra
really is identical in the y case you
just switch around the x's and the y's
but i just wanted to
make sure you realize that i'm just
doing a particular case of a hyperbola
that opens to the left and the right i
could call it a horizontal hyperbola
instead of a vertical one but i wanted
to make it clear that there is another
type of hyperbola
but anyway let's draw a graphical
representation of all this just to make
sure we understand or we re-understand
or better understand
what the foci points are and where they
sit on the hyperbola so those are my
axes
the asymptotes of this hyperbola are the
lines y is equal to plus or minus b over
a
we've gone
whoops not using my line tool
so
that's one
and
that's the other asymptote
and then
so the hyperbola will look something
like this
it'll look something like that it's
going to intersect it
a comma 0 right there this is going to
be a comma 0 and then intersect it minus
a comma 0. we saw all of this in the
previous video it looks something like
that
and then the focus points
are going to sit out here someplace
there and there and the focal length
this a squared plus b squared the square
root of a squared plus b squared that's
just this distance right here
that distance is the focal length so
this is going to be the point
f
0 and this is going to be the point
minus f
0.
now we learned in the last video that
one of the definitions of a hyperbola is
the locus of all points or the set of
all points where if i take the
difference of the distances to the two
foci that difference will be a constant
number
so if this is the point x comma y
and it could be any point that satisfies
this equation it's any point on the
hyperbola we know
or we are told
that if we take this distance right here
let's call that
d1
and subtract from that
the distance to the other
foci call that
d2
that that number is a constant
regardless of where we are on the
hyperbola in fact the locus of all
points are the hyperbola in fact is all
of the points that satisfy that
condition
and we learned in the last video just by
taking the distance
the difference of the distance we picked
this point we said okay what's that
distance minus that distance and we
figured out that it's 2a so d1
minus d2 is equal to i'm going off the
video screen d1 minus d2 is equal to 2a
so let's use
this fact right here that d1 minus d2 is
equal to 2a to try to prove
this
right there
so the first thing to do
is figure out what d1 and d2 are just
using the distance formula so what's d1
d1 is the distance between this point
and this point minus f zero so what you
do is this we just use the distance
formula which is really just the
pythagorean theorem so it's the
difference of difference of the x's it's
the x distance so it's x
minus minus f
squared
plus the y distance is y minus 0. so
that's just y
squared take the square root of that
so that's d1 right there
d1
and we want to subtract from that d2
right the difference of the distances
and in this case d1 is definitely bigger
than d2 oh you could take the absolute
value if you didn't want to worry about
that
and so here we get the square root
of x minus f
x minus f
squared
plus y squared and what does that equal
to well we said that equals to 2a that
equals
this distance right here so that is
equal to 2a now let's see if we can
simplify this at all
although an interesting thing to do
might just be to put this on the other
hand side other side of the equation
and this can get hairy so i really hope
i don't make any careless mistakes so
this becomes
and i write i might write small to save
space this becomes x plus f right minus
minus squared plus y squared is equal to
2 a plus
the square root
of x minus f
squared plus y squared
now to get rid of these radicals to
square both sides of this equation the
left hand side if you were to square it
just becomes
x plus f
squared plus y squared
and then to square this we have to this
we square the first term which is 4
a squared then we multiply the two terms
and multiply that by 2 right we're just
taking this whole thing and squaring it
so that's and this is just a review of
kind of binomial algebra so this is
equal to
plus 2a times this times 2 is
a
times the square root
of x minus f
squared plus y
y squared i want to lose that squared
right there and then we square this term
and this is just
multiplying a binomial so that's equal
to you just get rid of the radical sign
and i'm just now let me stay in that
color for now that's equal to
x minus f
squared plus y squared and already we it
looks like there's some cancellation
that we can do we can cancel out
there's a y squared on both sides of
this equation so let's just cancel those
out subtract y squared from both sides
of the equation and let's multiply this
term out so this right here is
x squared plus
x
f
plus
f squared
and then that is equal to
a squared plus 4a
times the square root
of
x minus actually well let me just write
x minus f
squared plus y squared
and then multiply this out plus x
squared minus 2 x f
plus f squared
and then let's see what can we cancel
out we have an x squared on both sides
of this we subtract x squared from both
sides of the equation we have an f
squared on both sides of the equation so
let's cancel that out
let's see what can we do to simplify it
so we have a minus 2xf and a plus 2xf
let's add 2xf to both sides of the
equation or bring this term over here so
if you add 2xf to both sides of this
equation see my phone is ringing let me
turn it off
if you add 2xf to both sides of this
equation what do you get you get
x f remember i just brought this term
over this this left hand side is equal
to
a squared
plus 4
a
times the square root of x minus f
squared plus y squared it's easy to get
lost in the algebra remember all we're
doing just to kind of
remind you of where what we're this
whole point was we're just simplifying
the difference of the distances between
these two points and then see how it
relates to the equation of the hyperbola
itself the a's and the b's
so let's take this 4a put it on this
side so you get 4
x
f
minus 4 a squared
is equal to 4 a
times the square root of
let's just multiply this out because
we'll probably have to eventually x
squared minus 2 x
f
plus
f squared plus y squared
that's this just multiplied out that's
the y squared right there
we could divide both sides of this by
four all i'm trying to do is just
simplify this as much as possible so
then this becomes
x f
minus
a squared
is equal to a times the square root of
this whole thing
x squared minus 2 x
f
plus
f squared plus y squared
and now we could square both sides of
of this equation right here and then if
you square both sides this side becomes
x
squared
f squared
minus
a squared x f
plus a to the fourth that's this side
squared and that's equal to
if you square the right hand side
a squared
times the square of the square root is
just that expression x squared
minus 2
x f
plus f squared plus y squared this
really is quite hairy
and let's see what we can do now to sim
let's divide both sides of of this
equation by a squared and then you get
x squared i'm really just trying to
simplify this as much as possible over a
squared
minus so the a squares cancel out minus
2 x f
plus a a to the fourth divided by a
squared well that's just a squared
so a squared is equal to
x squared minus 2 x f
plus
f squared
plus y squared well good there's
something to cancel out there's a minus
2 x f on both sides of this equation so
let's cancel that out
simplify our situation a little bit and
let's see we have
so we could do is subtract this x
squared from
this so you get let me rewrite it
so you get
you get x squared
f squared over a squared minus x squared
and let's bring this
let's bring this y to this side of the
equation too so minus y squared that's
all i did i just brought that to that
side
and then let's bring and i'm kind of
skipping a couple of steps but i don't
want to take too long let's take this a
and put it on that side of the equation
so we we took the x and the y we
put d we subtracted that from both sides
equation so they ended up on the
left-hand side and then if we subtract a
squared from both sides of this equation
this is a fatiguing problem then you get
f squared
minus a squared
i think we're almost there this can
simplify
to
let's see we can factor out the x
squared this becomes
f squared over a squared minus 1
times x squared i just factored out the
x squared there
minus y squared is equal to
f squared the focal length squared
minus a squared
and let's see let's divide both sides of
the equation by this expression right
there
and we get and this is this should start
to look familiar
we get
f
squared over a squared minus 1
x squared divided by
f squared minus a squared
minus y squared
over
f squared minus a squared is equal to
one right i divided both sides by this
so i just get a one on the this right
hand side let's see if i can simplify
this
if i multiply the numerator and the
denominator by a squared right if i if
as long as i multiply the numerator
denominator by the same number i'm just
multiplying by one so i'm not changing
anything so if i do that the numerator
becomes f
if i multiply it
it becomes f squared
minus a squared i'm just multiplying
that times a squared and the denominator
becomes a squared times f squared minus
a squared
and all of that times x squared
minus
y squared times f squared minus a
squared is equal to one
this cancels with this
and we get something that's starting to
look like the equation of a hyperbola my
energy is coming back
it seems like i see the light at the end
of the tunnel we get x squared over a
squared
minus
y squared over f squared minus a squared
is equal to one
now this looks a lot like our original
equation of the hyperbola which was x
squared
over a squared
minus y squared over b squared is equal
to one
in fact this is the equation of the
hyperbola but instead of writing b
squared since we wrote it we
we essentially said what is the locus of
all points where the difference of the
distances to those two foci is equal to
2a
and we just played with the algebra for
a while it was pretty tiring and i'm
impressed if you've gotten this far into
the video and we got this equation which
should be the equation of the hyperbola
it is the equation of the hyperbola it
is this equation
so this
is the same thing as that so f squared
minus a squared or the focal length
squared minus a squared is equal to
b squared you add a squared to both
sides and you get f squared is equal to
b squared plus a squared or a squared
plus b squared
which tells us that the focal length is
equal to the square root
of this
of a squared plus b squared and that's
what we set out to figure out in the
beginning
so hopefully you're now satisfied that
the focal length of a hyperbola is the
sum of these two denominators and if
this was an up and it's also true if
it's an upward or a vertical hyperbola
and if we're dealing with an ellipse
it's the difference of these two the
square root of the difference of these
two numbers anyway i'll leave you there
that was an exhausting problem i have to
go get a glass of water now